4:45 in the morning why am I getting up
so early
well today we're gonna really hit the
media trail we're gonna be switching
shark tank back to Friday night's this
Friday which is absolutely fantastic but
we gotta let the world know about it so
what am i doing I'm hitting everything
it's an action-packed day okay
let's get dressed oh yeah that's what
I'm talkin about
all right let's get out there and sell
some shark tank tonight tonight on ABC
at 8 o'clock is registration tentacle
tentacle the greatest shark deals of all
time are the greatest of all time of
shark wait wait you're just only do the
greatest shark deals of all time
greatest shark deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Robert hi I'm mark hi I'm mr.
wonderful and there's only one mister
and I'm Barbara and we're taking the
BuzzFeed quiz to find out which shark we
really are all right here we go let me
share this works use your finger this is
a computer Barbara three one two three
boom what a day so far we're just
action-packed here in Manhattan because
we've just done Good Morning America
then straight to the view and then TV
Guide stop the madness I'm only halfway
done okay we now welcome on very special
guests
it is mr. wonderful Kevin O'Leary from
shark tank Listerine and nyquil that
combine basically cut your beef I'm
getting ready for better time Hank don't
give up your day job
talk about a long day that was a killer
but was it worth it absolutely yes when
you're doing a big thing like moving a
show from Sunday night to Friday you've
got to let the whole world know and what
better way to do it then hit the road do
GMA do the view do all the social media
do TV Guide and do it together the
Sharks you know we never get together in
one city when we're not taping it's the
first time in a decade we've been able
to pull this off we're very proud of the
show and now as we go into our second
decade we're really thrilled that we're
moving it back to where it all started
Friday nights 8 o'clock oh yeah baby
all right let's go to the mailbox each
week I try and answer a question about
watches I get a lot of them I try and
pick one that's the most relevant I
nearly didn't want to read this one it's
from Mike in Chicago you'll see why in a
second here we go
hi mr. wonderful I was watching your
interview with Daymond John when you
were both talking about the high value
and high-end watches as an investment
then you started showing watches worth
more than $300,000 don't be ridiculous
most of us would rather buy a home than
a watch for that price I'm interested in
buying a good time piece but I want
something reasonable why don't you stop
being such a dick and give us some
practical and affordable ideas on
watches that are good buys well okay
Mike I said it's a little negativity
there on the other hand you make a very
good point what I was talking about in
that hole Daymond John interview we were
talking about watches and we were
talking about
appreciation and investment value and
that the timepiece you're talking about
was the Rolex Daytona rainbow rose gold
yeah it's a crazy watch and by the way I
think I said that interview I wouldn't
be buying anything watches or houses
right now because we're in a really
crazy time but I was trying to make a
point about invest ability however
you're right and by the way I wear lots
of watches that don't cost crazy money
so what I'm gonna do now is I'm going to
go through five great pieces that I
think are very fine watches very
affordable I think they're spectacular
because I'll tell you my definition of a
investable watch regardless of price
does it come from an established watch
maker in other words they have their own
watchmakers they make their own
movements do they have a history and you
know that's very important to me I don't
like jewelers I don't want some random
movement put into a jewelry box that's
none that I'm interested me I want a
real brand and then number two is it's
got to have a spectacular dial what
makes a watch amazing is it style is the
dial it's it's it doesn't connect with
you does it tell a story is it beautiful
so I'm gonna walk you through some
incredible pieces and I wear these
pieces and you're gonna be hopefully
very happy with the price Mike because I
think one of these is perfect for you
we're gonna go up in steps in value
we're gonna start and I'm gonna tell you
what brands are gonna look at we're
going to look at loan gene which is a
legendary Swiss watch company makes
fantastic watches and amazing dials at
very affordable prices we have to look
at grande Seiko maybe the best value in
in collectible watches right now two
amazing pieces I'm going to show you and
then the entry-level FP Jorn now Jordan
is one of those out there independent
watchmakers crazy prices but there is an
entry-level watch which I think is
spectacular at the high end of our price
range but I'm going to walk you through
it so let's start with long gene this I
wear this watch all the time this is a
beautiful dial it's a spectacular dial
it's got blue on steel which i think is
absolutely gorgeous it's called the
conquest it's 41 millimeters I have a
tricked out with a red band because I
wear it on television but I mean there
is nothing wrong with this watch and
you're ready for the price this includes
tax 862 dollars I have it on my
spreadsheet right here 862 Mike that's
not a bad deal for a spectacular looking
watch it's absolutely gorgeous 862 bucks
you can't buy a house with $862 but you
can buy this watch alright I don't wanna
sound nasty Mike but I you know I'm
taking I'm not taking offense look I
read the question right I and I think
you made a great point maybe might hurt
my feelings or her a little bit anyways
now this piece my wife tried to steal
from me she loves it it's an oversized
also a long Jean
let me check the price you're gonna love
this this is a hydro conquest 43
millimeter dive watch a beautiful steel
on blue of ceramic it's just I mean that
is a good-looking watch you ready for
the price here I can't believe it I put
my glasses on to make sure I don't get
it wrong
thirteen hundred and sixty three dollars
and twenty cents with tax this is a
fantastic piece now it's a men's watch
women dig it - my wife wants it that's
why I haven't tricked it over the red
band yet she doesn't want a red man she
doesn't like red bands I like red bands
but I know she's trying to steal this
from me she wants to wear it in the
summer women are into these big dials
now they look you know it's a fashion
thing okay
moving up the feeding chain here this is
a spectacular piece this grand Seiko now
I wear this on television it's tricked
out with a red band it's the best of
mechanical and quartz mixed together but
what's incredible about this watch and
when people see it and look at it it's
the perfect sweep of the second hand and
that's the whole magic of the spring
Drive the combo quartz and mechanical
let me check the price on this puppy
it's a little bit more a production
watch so you can probably get one if you
go to a grand Seco boutique fifty six
hundred and ninety-four dollars Mike
fifty six hundred ninety four and it is
a listen this is one of the most
legendary movements out there and by the
way you want to talk about crunch factor
the beautiful feel of winding a grand
Seco I mean this puppy is just
magnifique really nice piece really nice
piece 56 94 with tax and now ooh la la
this just got released this is the 60th
anniversary I haven't got the red band
on yet I just got this piece this is the
60th anniversary Gantt grande Seco
already nicknamed all around the world
the Superman incredible blue on steel
amazing polish only 1500 made so if you
like this piece and when you hear the
price I think you're gonna like the
price too and you want one you better
you know chop-chop you're gonna have to
call a grand Seco boutique they have one
in New York one in LA and probably you
can probably look online for two
fifteen hundred now tell you why I like
this piece this is very collectible at a
very affordable price and the price on
this poppy $6,300 for a piece of which
they're only 1,500 and it's got the high
beat 36,000 it's a really fantastic
watch the thirty-six thousand is also a
legendary movement made by Seiko I don't
want to get in all the tech but it's
very very accurate just beautiful piece
you know I love that I love that so if
you're into collectability you got to
get moving all right let's move it up
the feeding chain of it I said I was
going to show you something special now
this is an FP Zord this is called the
elegant and this is an incredible watch
it's quartz but it's legendary it's
brought out in 2014 for women only
that's when they started you can see it
moving it's going it's doing something
I'm going to talk to you about a minute
it's finding the right time because it
went to sleep for a while what this
incredible watch does is when it's laid
to rest anywhere for thirty five minutes
it goes to sleep but it remembers the
time that's what's so cool about it
nobody would collect you know quartz
watches back years ago until this thing
came out and then they started saying
wait a second this is an amazing piece
so in 2016 FP join was convinced by all
the guy collectors to make one this is
titanium with a tent on the kind of knot
tantalum it's a it's a I got to get the
pronunciation of this title it coated
it's just it's a it's a gray beautiful
just gorgeous style now this puppy is
eleven thousand four hundred and twenty
eight dollars and sixty seven cents it's
the really the only journey can jump in
the water with it's got a screw down
crown but this incredible feature where
you can leave it in a drawer the battery
lasts let me check the stats on this
thing the battery lasts eight to ten
years when you wear it normally but
because of this feature where it goes to
sleep you can put it in a drawer for two
years and it remembers the time and then
under that scenario battery can last up
to eighteen years that's incredible
alright so I've given you kind of let me
put it up on a graphic again let me show
you the dun dun dun stairway up but
they're all entry level watch
they're all spectacular they're all
beautiful right from under $1,000 on the
loan gene this amazing blue dial right
up to past 11,000 on the FP Jorn but
they're all gorgeous watches you know in
my view the best value you can get at
these price points and all have
beautiful dials which is the only reason
you should buy watch in the first place
there Micha got off my chest very
affordable great deals you should choose
one of these
[Music]